I'm gonna talk about to my heroes
somebody get out of here has anyone
heard of Coco the gorilla Wow I'm sure
you guys Coco the gorilla for those that
don't know is a gorilla that speaks
fluent sign language and in 1999 this is
true
Coco met Robin Williams in last year
they told Coco Robin Williams had passed
away in cocoa went Coco friend Coco sad
yeah which is sad but on the plus side
how funny was Robin Williams that even
gorillas were like this guy is
unbelievable my comedy barely works if
you're not a Jew from New York City
Robin Williams crossed the species
barrier that's the best comedian second
of all and obviously did they have to
tell the gorillas that Robin Williams
had passed away she wasn't gonna catch
it on CNN or anything like that
so watch it - a gorilla enclosure like
early 2008 she's like hi Coco can you
put down the banana
we have bad news and they tell KOCO
Coco's like but princes fine rights
get the gun Coco calm down at Coco's
like why was the last David Bowie album
so sad and they're like Oh God
it goes like well scheana you know like
now and how it was like you know like no
and coke was like who's the president
now I know I should we tell her he's a
relative my other hair growing up was
Neil Armstrong and not just to see one
of those bicycle races because he was
the first guy to walk on the moon that
was America's best moment I loved it was
American 50 years ago 30 years ago this
year that wasn't America's best moment
we Russia to the moon in the middle of a
cold war and Russian spaceships are
really expensive really well-designed
because what you build a Russian
spaceship is different the way you build
a Russian space you do one large
container and they take the top off and
there's a smaller container inside of it
and they take top of that then a smaller
container inside then you tell you top
of that there's a smaller container
inside I would do this until everybody
is laughing they take top of that and in
the middle babushka
and America sent three men in this space
they sent Buzz Aldrin they sent Neil
Armstrong and no one ever knows the
third guy is this Michael Collins no one
ever knows a third guy and that's
horrible because Neil option might be
like one of the most famous men of the
20th century Michael Collins third guy
on that mission he is it even the most
famous Michael Collins
there's a movie called Michael Collins
starring Liam Neeson it's about a
different guy in America sent these
three guys in a space thing of four days
to get there I know times when they got
there but it was nighttime because the
mood was out and then exactly 35 years
later I met Neil Armstrong on an
elevator in New York I walked in is
totally true and he was right there and
I was like mr. Armstrong I said can I
have your autograph and he said I don't
do that nice and mr. Armstrong could can
I have a picture with you and he said I
don't do that I said mr. Armstrong could
I shake your hand and I'll never forget
this he just looked at me he went kid go
away
you've only known me for a couple
minutes but if you need to know one
thing about me it's this if I'm not
having a good time no one's having a
good time and because it was 15 and I
only knew from sarcasm Neil Armstrong
and I said this is the worst make a wish
I could have possibly asked
and then thinking this would genuinely
sting I went my favorite should have
been Michael Collins and Neil Armstrong
took a step away from me and it was a
small step for Neil Armstrong you guys
been really wonderful thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]